60% des français n'ont pas respecté les
règles du deuxième confinement c'est le
résultat d'un sondage ifop sorti
aujourd'hui les personnes interrogées
aurait transgressé au moins une fois les
interdits imposés par le gouvernement en
se rendant chez des amis ou en utilisant
l'attestation de déplacement pour un
autre motif que ceux indiqués et vous
avez-vous réussi à vous plier à ses
obligations
deux semaines après le début du nouveau
confinement ont fait le bilan avec lucas
chopin et paul boyer ce deuxième
confinement est définitivement plus
léger que le premier
moins de trois semaines après leur
confinement certains expriment déjà leur
exaspération
il s'autorise même quelques sorties j'ai
envie de sortir aller faire mon sport je
continue à le faire donc après mais oui
c'est chiant ce que les attestations des
trucs c'est un peu je trouve une
atteinte à nos libertés
je n'ai pas non plus envie de respecter
forcément tout le temps mais je sais de
respecter un minimum après c'est vrai
que voilà on fait comme on peut
côté étudiants ont dit pas non à
quelques verres entre amis histoire
d'oublier cette période anxiogène on
essaie de réduire les effectifs de faire
gaffe on voit pas dans les verres des
autres etc
mais on organise deux trois trucs quand
même des petites soirées un petit comité
avec les gens de notre classe pour voir
le jour mais on les côtoie dans le lycée
où on dort à la limite ça servait un peu
même on essaie de faire gaffe quand même
des attestations de sortie qui embête
les jeunes et les moins jeunes
remplissez des formulaires aller sur
internet
allez vous faire chier pour
avoir des documents qui vous permettent
de circuler pas circuler et c'est non
mais où on va là où est ce qu'on va j'en
ai ras-le-bol
mais elle est vraiment ras la soupape la
fin du confinement n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour
le pic de l'épidémie est attendu pour la
semaine prochaine